a minha família ela sempre veio da roça
eu sempre gostei de estar no meio da
floresta
a minha vida no meio da floresta foi
conviver com os animais e o meu foco
maior foi trabalhar com as crianças
criança de 4 anos de idade até a
adolescência e vai passando pelo viaduto
na comunidade
mas comecemos a trabalhar com lixo e eu
fui conscientizando as pessoas como
coletar diz saber separar o lixo do
outro então eu tentei conversar com as
crianças e foi ganhando confiança dos
pais
os pais foram pegando empregando as
crianças
as pessoas me reconhecem na comunidade e
eu estudei apenas até 8ª séria não tive
o privilégio de uma escola para informar
mas hoje em dia me sinto como um
educador e passa com as crianças que eu
sei
na minha comunidade nós tem um uma
coleta de sementes quando se vai para a
floresta para trabalhar com mais afinco
a gente tem um plantio lá que eu conheci
uma planta que se chama o nome dela de
engasgar
ela é uma planta leguminosa que a gente
planta de um tudo embaixo dela é uma
planta que recupera rápido no solo e
todas as plantas que a gente planta
debaixo dela a gente tem um bom
resultado em nossa comunidade
quando foi para a embrapa lá eu conheci
que todas planta era era utilizada cada
um no seu lugar mas eu tentei imitar com
uma floresta imita então a pt mt
floresta porque lá na embrapa tinha
muito praga que estava dando mais planta
e lá nossa floresta eu vi que não tinha
praga né
então eu tentei implantar elas variando
né
lá e tenho a saiu o público gritava
'olé' a andiroba copaíba cumbaru guaraná
e tudo lá não da praga noite comigo lá
tudo natural na embrapa eu vi que tinha
muito veneno muito tóxico da embrapa e a
fruta de lado sem comparação da nossa em
nossa comunidade
o nosso trabalho lá tudo orgânico você
come tudo natural não tem toques em
nossa comunidade
eu comparo o ser humano como animal a
criança ela comparou ela com um papagaio
você fala ela fica ouvindo e depois vai
passando pelas crianças a pagar e ficar
ouvindo presta atenção
depois ele começa a conversar com outro
animal
então é com para crianças e para lidar
com o ser humano
a gente tem que ser paciente tem que
mostrar o amor tem que ter o carinho o
maior cuidado pelas crianças
então isso foi buscando meu conhecimento
e foi botando tudo no meu pai
o primeiro ensinamento que a gente tem
que passar a pessoa tem que vim da casa
da gente então eu sou uma pessoa que
sempre por onde eu ando eu fico
observando uma pessoa que observe a casa
observando a minha casa e vi que a minha
esposa está tudo as coisas tudo bem
arrumadinho
então eu vi que tudo isso esse meu
trabalho é fazer com que a criança tinha
futuro e é dar certo e hoje nós tem um
trabalho lá dentro do ato humano
quando eu comecei lá começou em
é a tartaruga da amazônia
a gente trabalha lá que começou com mil
filhotes hoje a gente está abrangido 25
mil filhotes ea gente tá repovoando rio
que antes tinha uma barragem na frente é
assim um pouco da nossa comunidade e
essa barragem estourou e acabou com o
rio e hoje nós temos repovoando rio
hoje lá na situação uma situação assim
bem alegre que tá conseguindo a viver
com a natureza entender a natureza e eu
sempre gostei da floresta pode passar
com as pessoas hoje em dia quando eu
falo em floresta daqui converse com ela
para quem sente respirar um ar puro
ali então eu a minha vivência na
floresta é sempre está conversando com
as pessoas e educando as crianças e
outras pessoas e eu tenho um recado a
deixar aqui uma frase que ela é bem
pequenininha
eu sou assim eu ando eu toda a
comunidade chega às pessoas e vem pro se
aproxima de nós
a light vai falando vai conscientizar as
pessoas e eu fico muito feliz eu eu sou
assim eu se eu não passar a minha
mensagem a má educação para as outras
pessoas
eu me sinto até culpado o pessoal e
muito obrigada pessoal
[Aplausos]
em 2010